we're back in the studio hey hey we're
back hold on hold on your discord [ __ ]
up
oh sorry hello hello do you aren't you
hear me yeah i can hear you
psych congrats man
thank you dude yeah you see the ring um
if i just pull out of prince albert
right now
what the ring that she gave you oh um
oh wait no no i actually have right here
[Laughter]
yeah that's the way it should work dude
yeah boys should get the ring
yeah boys should get the ring we put in
all the effort dude walk around with a
crispy diamond on
hey listen my whole theory
or my whole take on this is men go
through a certain kind of labor too
what women go through labor for the baby
we go through it
can't wait to hear this we go through
labor for that diamond
pushing that diamond out is a year's
long process right yeah i see
yeah when that was swiping the card on
that and pushing it out was like
oh how'd it feel um it was cool but then
i had to deliver it you know what i mean
like that's just like like when you get
the ring you're just crowning at that
point okay you know what i mean like
it's just like it's just starting to
come out and then when you deliver it to
her it's like
you feel like your insides go with it
you're like oh
yeah yeah yeah it's like this like
transfer of life it's yeah
it's amazing right but and then it's in
her care though yeah
yeah now she's got to take care of it
yeah exactly yeah now girl get the [ __ ]
off
it's like there and now you got that big
responsibility on your head it's just
like a baby
just like a baby yeah all right i'm a
yeah i'm late i'm gonna leave
my ubers here that's all you though yeah
bet just let me know when the wedding is
and i'll be there yeah i'm i'm gonna
pull up
i'm gonna be there i'm definitely gonna
be there you guys know when the
wedding's gonna be
[ __ ] no man we don't know what venues
are like we covered and [ __ ] yeah
it was funny we were like thinking about
it and
we we're just i mean i don't wanna
whatever if a family member hears this
[ __ ] i wanna piss him off but
we're kind of like man why even oh no
why even
why even do one just do like a shotgun
wedding sort over
i was saying we do it like a tour like
we just get a motor home okay and we
just drive around different families
houses and we just like do it on the
front doorstep it's like
it's like a show they couldn't be mad at
that yeah they just stand and bring them
to them yeah yeah that's awesome yeah
we'll buy like however many bouquets
alina will throw it over her shoulder
you know be [ __ ] sick yeah yeah go to
a wedding yeah
and they just came to you yeah that's
what i'm saying damn yeah
still gonna sell tickets though like
it's not free like they have yeah yeah
right open bar though
yeah yeah definitely yeah yeah yeah
there's like a one-hour pre-show where
they can get drinks
so like if they want to be if they want
to see the wedding yeah they can pay
yeah gas is expensive yeah yeah if they
want to see us like want this vip yeah
they can meet us one-on-one oh yeah yeah
it's like a meet and greet for the
wedding
so it's a you know it'll be a full tour
but
yeah i don't know man it's it's
definitely cool like
but it doesn't really feel that
different yeah you know it's been
together so long
i'm sure like being married is the same
thing that's what everyone said yeah
yeah we
did it now it's the same i'll tell you
the um
there's adrenaline nothing like that
though yeah yeah
i think that's what meth feels like okay
like the 60 seconds
leading up to it i think it's like meth
is like that for 15.
if that's what meth is like i would do
that [ __ ]
this is the craziest feeling i've had in
a while man really yeah
yeah you feel like you're like whole
inside shivering like
like your your intestines are vibrating
like going into so you mean the
feeling before you mean that ah after
before
okay the before is for sure meth okay
the after is just like oh like it's okay
yeah that's the part that's supposed to
be like euphoric right it's like she
said yes
yeah yeah we're good i want the before
part you want you like that that [ __ ] i
felt like i could punch through brick
it was crazy we just watched this
episode of black mirror last night
about the guy who the doctor that
created the little implant that he could
feel other people's pain
you ever seen that yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah same [ __ ] yeah yeah
he started getting off on the pain yeah
so he would like find yeah ring people
and just
like let them suffer so that he could
listen man you like you want that
feeling yeah nervous that
that level of adrenaline and nerve was
wild
i've not like i was i said before
performing in australia didn't hold a
candle to that
i think it would take 20 000 people to
make me feel ashade of what that was
damn it was crazy that's wild yeah yeah
you got it done i know but i think i
want to do it again so i can feel it
again
like i'm going to take the ring back and
then ask her again and just like
you know i need that hit i need a hit
babe like you don't
you don't know when it's coming
[Laughter]
start a fight call it off yeah just pop
it again
yeah this is done i can't believe you
i'm gonna take that back
all right fellas for this one i'm
thinking i'm gonna do it even crazier
i'll do it in a helicopter i'm gonna
suspend us both by rope it's gonna be a
stunt
and then i'll do it in the air i think
you would pass out like doing a proposal
like with a stunt involved
yeah i don't know how guys do the whole
multi-step all right we're gonna go here
and then it's gonna be i don't
that [ __ ] is yeah yeah like
yeah i think actually that's how you
prolong the high so actually i commend
it
yeah yeah yeah we were watching um who
was the one of the guys from hamilton
married
one of the girls from hamilton dope
yeah this is you know it wasn't it was
my
first choice you know it wasn't me that
was that didn't show up on my
recommendation sure yeah sure
but you know what you pick way better
proposal videos yeah mine are way better
yeah yours are like
hot air balloon yeah [ __ ] extreme
extreme proposal video
[ __ ] black diamond
will you marry me
mukbang yeah were they just in the
middle of the chinese food
but we were watching it and he was like
he like coordinated all the family and
everything and i'm like oh
hell nah that that's just such a like i
would just be so
nervous you know i think nah man because
the theater
dweebs i know for both of them it was
like
they i think he was trying to add the
audience because he was he had a whole
but it didn't end up being like a big i
thought it was gonna be the same thing
where he was gonna like
you know make them i guess like
coordinate them in a certain area and
then be a photographer and all this
stuff
no the dude filming is like standing
beside them and they're all just looking
at this castle and he just
like on the sidewalk just bust down on
his knee and asked her and all the
family is like
crowded around that circle it was
actually pretty
pretty dope i thought it was going to be
like a whole performance then once he
busted it out they were going to do like
a
a theater kid like crying match like see
who can be more hysterical
and then just like the family's like
here they go again
i can't [ __ ] believe this and they're
both like
[Music]
no those are only youtube proposals okay
youtube proposals are the worst ones
fair
yeah by the way i just want to give a
big shout out to everyone who got mad at
me for eating
last episode i apologize that was my
only time to eat
and as a way to say sorry cody and i
have actually ordered a cake and i'm
going to eat it
for the last 30 minutes of the episode
yep
it's just a happy proposal on it no i
didn't realize it
i didn't realize on my mic it wasn't
there i was like leaning away i didn't
hear it at all
so i thought it was good but apparently
i wasn't
it i mean first off we do apologize
right no yeah excuse for us to be
[ __ ] around the mics
no i at this point no i genuinely did
not
hear it i like actually didn't hear it
but i will say
it is kind of [ __ ] hilarious how mad
people get it
you